because like it's uh it's working on my  main game but not on the on the analysis  game for some reason  uh it's on me  but  yeah it runs away yeah you go King g2f3  F3 and then you run to H4 you still have  to be a bit precise but it's not very  difficult and then you just give me it  has 30 seconds here so I assume he'll be  okay  uh you have you have something to click  to turn the engine on  um okay yeah and that's the end of the  game yeah wow thank you that is  incredible yeah coming up missing Magnus  is uh  obviously celebrates yeah very big  result and yeah popping off there is  appropriate  it does look like Magnus is at home by  the way because unless he travels with  the secret Labs chair  and who wouldn't I mean